d'amateurs avec notre collègue du à
panel alex chantal michel à montréal on
va parler du prime du bilan du premier
voyage de justin trudeau à l'étranger si
vous voulez on peut peut-être entendre
un extrait de l'ambiance ou de l'accueil
qu'on lui a réservé au sommet de l'apec
attends je vais commencer avec vous
parce que le sourire en disait beaucoup
ce que ces sacs aussi du voyage de
monsieur trudeau cette semaine n'ont pas
seulement ce serait ce qu'un jour ça je
pense que de façon générale
en marge de sa gestion assez médiocre
des communications sur l'attentât qui
met sur l'exercice comme tel monsieur
trudeau s'en est plutôt bien tiré
ç'a bien été dans ces rencontres
bilatérales
il s'est pas trompé de pays
contrairement à d'autres avant lui mais
il était présent pour des photos comment
j'ai pu voir c'est un problème c'était
peut-être décalage entre le style de
monsieur trudeau les ciels fille les
autoportraits et tout ça est l'ambiance
à l'extérieur ou au canada on trouve
dans la foulée des attentats de taille
le décalage était évident mais sur le
fond monsieur trudeau a présenté la
position canadienne tels qu'on les a
connus en campagne électorale sur des
sujets d'importance à ces partis étaient
simplement bien avec mon voyage pour
justin trudeau
oui mais j'ai l'impression qu'elle
connut deux types de voyages notre
collègue emmanuelle latraverse utilisé
l'expression monde parallèle
je trouve que c'est assez bien exprimer
c'est à dire on a l'impression que
t'être doit assez bien réussi la partie
g20 et sommet de l'apec rencontres
bilatérales comme chantal de pauw fait
de garde particulière il parle du sujet
important d'infrastructures climat
classes moyennes mais en même temps on a
l'impression que vu du sivu du canada
c'est pour ça qu'on attendait justin
trudeau s'est pas nécessairement qu'ils
performent plutôt correctement les bords
ou lécher repos derrière la diplomatie
canadienne avait visiblement très bien
préparé ses premiers pas sur la scène
internationale on voulait en entendre
parler des attentats de paris qui
rassure les canadiens quel va être le
rôle du canada dans la lutte contre le
groupe armé tu as les mecs les élus de
ce côté là un gros problème de
communication on attend encore le plan
sur les réfugiés qu'est ce qu'on va
faire concrètement pour vous pour
rejoindre la communauté nationale contre
le groupe armé islamique dont quelqu'un
qui regarde ce dc a l'impression que
justin trudeau vivait dans un autre
monde le boc et tout s'est bien passé
mekhissi s'est pas nécessairement ce
qu'on attendait de notre premier
ministre monsieur je vais chercher de la
tête sans manquer de substance
le problème c'est pas le fond c'est le
temps c'est celle fils et des choses
comme ça alors que pour la flamme et
canadiens qui le gardait la tv il voyait
les attentats de paris voyait là la
menace terroriste lui les plus graves
attentats depuis le 11 septembre dans le
monde occidental puis c'est de ça qu'il
voulait voir le premier ministre leur
parler et ça va l'être peu frivole pensé
voir le mot parce que c'est celle qui me
vient à l'esprit de voir monsieur
trudeau jouer ou celle fille pendant ce
temps là ça veut pas dire que ceux qui à
faire formellement à l'apec n'a pas été
bien fait le problème aussi par là cette
semaine là ça a été de ceux s'enfarger
dans des modalités plutôt que dans des
principes en particulier sur les
réfugiés tenir mordicus à la date du 31
décembre alors que tous et toutes les
provinces
toutes les grandes villes dit écoutez
c'est peut-être pas de meilleur moyen
peut-être qu'on va peut-être avoir un
problème avec ça si on si on se tient
mordicus à cette date là ce trio il ya
tenu mordicus ben ça c'est c'était aussi
dans le ton de la semaine et ça c'est
une mauvaise note pour lui cette semaine
chantal lune de miel est elle terminée
maintenant que
elle est moins on en fait plus les
casseroles derrière la voiture
on est en train de couper les fils alors
qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'on juge
là-dessus où on attend le prochain
voyage me suis trop d'eau par quoi mardi
ou mercredi là pour une autre série de
notre série de rencontres comme le dit
je pense pas que ce soit le problème que
ce soit le voyage je pense qu'il va
encore être tout à fait correcte au
sommet du commonwealth
je pense pouvoir ne s'amendent de
décrochage de boeck est plus sujet à des
dégâts face au sommet là qu'il l'était
au g20 ou au sommet de l'apec au contrat
je pense que comme une voie ce devrait
être encore plus l'encadrer qu'il était
dans les derniers sommets mais je pense
qu'on a besoin d'avoir une connexion
avec les canadiens on a l'impression du
côté des canadiens que justin trudeau a
eu un très bon premier dix jours où l'on
y avait un manque ont marqué un
changement dit il avec le gouvernement
harper s'était bienvenus on voyait que
la lune de miel était bien entamée puis
là il ya eu un décrochage
il ya beaucoup de gens encore qu'il
doutait que justin trudeau était capable
sur la scène internationale de tenir son
bout par rapport à des barack obama
david cameron angela merkel et 110 que
ça a été difficile parce que je pense
qu'ils étaient tout à fait correct on
n'a pas eu l'impression qu'ils nous ont
rassurés n'ont plus qu'à pas été
nécessairement un chef d'état la hauteur
de ce qu'on attendait quand il ya des
attentats comme ceux qui se sont
produits
et là je pense que c'est avec les
canadiens qu'il faut qu'ils soient
capables de raccommoder les choses pour
nécessairement par rapport aux sommets
ses collègues etc
je pense qu'il doit commencer par luca
n'a dit avant tout là j'ai envie de
parler il faut parler en fait la
rencontre de demain qu'on dit prêt
ministre ottawa fédérale-provinciale tc
première depuis neuf ans maintenant
quelle est l'importance de cette
rencontre là qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
doit comprendre de ce qui se prépare
dans tout ce monde là bas ce soir autour
de la terre les prémices des provinces
des territoires et monsieur trudeau
michel dans la volière chose qui est
importante c'est qu'elle ait lieu
vous dites ne venge pas c'est un petit
peu moins que ça y en avait eu en 2007
mais il reste que le geste est important
de dire aux saveurs paris a été
convoquée sur le climat d'abord on va
parler d'autre chose était convoquée sur
le climat on s'en va à paris on va se
parler en d'y aller c'est quelque chose
de relativement il faudra la politique
canadienne monsieur harper faisait pas
ça et même si à la fin on n'aura pas de
cible précise qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
d'en faire sadibou
comment fédéral au moins on tout le
monde doit être un peu sur la même page
on va aussi par les réfugiés parce que
c'est inévitable
et là ils vont peut-être en plus de
diffuser de difficultés pour monsieur
trudeau parce que on attend toujours le
plan qui devrait sortir de mardi dont
mardi là on va être six semaines cinq
semaines de la fin de l'année vingt-cinq
mille réfugiés dans cinq semaines
c'est un effort de logistique absolument
extraordinaire au canada commence à
presser champagne il ya un conseil de la
fédération aussi avant la rencontre
c'est normal le conseil de la fédération
évolué et évoluent et beaucoup pendant
les années de stephen harper c'est
intéressant parce que vendredi 4 et non
en effet le couillard était ensemble une
conférence à ottawa pour parler
justement changement climatique et ils
ont dit chacun une chose qui est
importante pour des raisons différentes
pour ce qui va se passer demain à ottawa
madame wang qui dit pendant que ce qui
venait à peu nous ignorer nous les
enfants à la table on a appris à bien
jouer ensemble
je voulais dire c'est que les provinces
se sont parlé de changement climatique
l'arrivée d'un gouvernement
néo-démocrate en alberta évidemment ça
fait une grosse différence des philippe
couillard avait aussi quelque chose de
très important surtout qu une demi heure
après le ministre des finances a fait
son annonce il dit à la fin ça va quand
même être une question d'argent c'est
toujours une question d'argent avec ça
parle beaucoup d'environnement par une
réfugiée aux six autres que des peluches
et construction est intéressant du moins
chez pas ça va être plus équilibré ça
fait intéressant les provinces pour le
dire colabor assez bien entre elles un
chantal par led effectivement aux
huîtres sont habitués à travailler sans
gouvernement fédéral mais on y rencontre
téléphonique assez régulièrement le
conseil de la fédération c'est plus
uniquement une rencontre par année et
puis on fait un spectacle avec seul il
ya à peine un mois ils étaient tous au
téléphone et premiers ministres qui
discutaient des jeunes
qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient faire dans l
dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques qui avaient commencé à
parler des réfugiés un peu sans voix
évidemment le plan parce qu'on avait pas
le même gouvernement qui est là donc ça
veut dire que justin trudeau arrive
quand même à un sommet comme celui là
avec des provinces qui savent s'en vont
qui ont des objectifs précis qui vont
avoir des demandes
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on va tous se
liguer contre le gouvernement fédéral
non je pense qu'on est conscient qu'on
va vouloir travailler avec lui il vient
d'arriver
on va avoir 80 travail
le gouvernement trudeau donc je pense
qu'on va faire les choses en conséquence
mais ça veut aussi dire que ça soit pas
nécessairement fondés organisé ce justin
trudeau d'avoir à venir compte y compris
pour le le dossier des réfugiés ou là il
ya de la nervosité dans certaines
provinces pour le financement pour les
modalités ils vont devoir être rassurés
je pense à la rencontre de lundi
maintenant on va voir pendant plus de
détails demain ça se passe à ottawa
toute la journée et à une partie de la
soirée à vous de voir merci beaucoup
bonne semaine